こんにちははじめ社長です皆様ベイブレードってご存知でしょうか
多分知っている人が多いと思うんですけどもついては豪州と取ってこうやって駒が凄い
高速回転して戦わせるやつなんですけども
ブーブー言って回転させるわけですからものというものは回転している時にやてぃ面と
の設置面によるマティきた方がいいなぁ名大回転するがどうしてもブーバーこのように
回転してるか
となってしまうそれはなぜかまずイベントは接地面による摩擦
これで9位なスピード低下が起きてしまうとやはりこのまあねが蓄積しているので回転
することによって安倍を切りされているのでハゼの抵抗によって回転力がダウンですよ
あとは傾きですねバランスが悪いベイベーだと回転した時の傾きによってスピードの
低下につながってしまう
いろんな要因でベイブレードは改善するものも一夫顔止まってしまうのだが私は今回
このベイブレード
止めずに回転させスズデン続けるぞてちょっと私は今回このベイブレード延々に回転さ
せ続けることをカーボンにしようと思う
あっまあ正直できるかわかんないんですけども弾んで着るのであればこれしかない
でしょ
こちら超強力ブロアーレディブルワーズ何が
と言いますと扇風機とは違いましてもう局所的にものすごく強い風を出すまでご覧
ください
もう音を聞くとビックリしますよ
ブーフ
あーやばい私の理論が正しいと例えばこちらのビジネスのスラッシュヴァルキリーに彼
等を見てみましょが大きくさん前歯ありますよね私が今回準備したブロガーも3つ
つまりバランスよく風を当て続けるとバランス問題はまず解決して風を回転する方向と
同じます当てることによってポレット待ってるとさらに好風を当ててさらにか
て力を上げることによってすごくバランスよく強力な風を送り続けることによって米
メイドえいえんに開店する
そんな気がしてならないのですよどっから見てこれマジでちょっと強いですそれで3つ
まるで本当に強力だと思うんで売れないっていうか確かめてみましょう
じゃお前マジでヤバイいやーこれたと風力的にはかなり間違いないと思いますでは準備
してみましょう
男女の周りのこの年か透明の部分を外しますこれ本当安全装置なんで絶対つけて対戦し
なきゃいけないんですけども
今回実験ということで外させていただきますみなさんはこれをつけてさんと遊んで
くださいなんでこれ初したかと言いますと風がちゃんと直に当たるように
しましたついては5勝2敗
いつも結構回転できる時給方にさせていただきました公開でんそれから風をこう当てれ
ばいいんだな
[音楽]
はいて上で完成しました
これで一応理論像は a に回ると思われます
ベリーはこうやって改定するんで相手方向の羽の向きに沿って強風が当たるのでも
めちゃくちゃ綺麗に回転し続けるのではないかなと思っておりますで早速増していき
ましょうまずして見て見ますいい
とぅ
んこ ok さあここから風を当てていきましょう
see to one year
[音楽]
田子はつバランスじゃねえちょっと距離話し合い撮ってみましょう家庭の
風強いんだなちょっと数弱めて行ってみますのブーツ
えっ結構いいんだねこれ
良いと思ったこともあるじゃない yeah
[音楽]
ええの
ええええええ
なんねーよああ図5は待つよね
[音楽]
ran
eran
car
無理でしたうーん
[音楽]
me
teame
はぁ
あああああ